all right here are the facts a few hours
ago I would have told you that it is
impossible to be surprised by a slasher
flick about five idiots who go into a
cabin and get slashed up and killed
however I just saw cabin in the woods
and now I would beg to differ my
friend's cabin in the woods
so when starting out I'll let you know
initially cabin in the woods is about
five college students who all go into a
cabin you know drink and party and get
away and then bad things start happening
they start getting killed before you
turn this review off because you're
uninterested there's a little more to it
than that right so I had heard that Joss
Whedon was one of the producers at this
movie but I didn't know he was one of
the writers I found out he was one of
the writers in the opening scene of the
movie when two people were talking and
five lines in I was like Joss Whedon
totally wrote this dialogue it just has
that Joss Whedon ISM about it you know
it's funny and it's realistic like if
you took that funny caricature dialogue
that Tarantino is known for you know the
really realistic dialogue really like I
could see two people having that
conversation if they did have that
conversation it would be the perfect
conversation for those two people to
have in that moment and he took out all
the f-bombs you'd have a Joss Whedon
script tell me the analogies not perfect
but that's the best I can describe it
cabin in the woods has a pretty you know
it's a good cast we got Chris Hemsworth
Thor it's not completely uncredible he
sees four you got Topher brink from dull
house that like solidifies the Joss
Whedon ISM any pretty much plays Topher
bring from dollhouse he's still kind of
ducks like this you know really
exaggerated but he's really high all the
time in this movie he's you know he
smokes a lot of weed which is funny cuz
you look around you're like this is the
absolute crew that would go into the
cabin in the woods and get killed among
the really slick dialog and it being
funny in a really dark way cabin in the
woods absolutely celebrates horror
movies for horror movie fans and
absolutely deconstructs them to the bone
and a movie like this comes along every
couple of decades there has not been a
modern horror movie lately that's as
unique as cabin in the woods cabin the
woods is like Rain Man not like the Rain
Man movie but the Rain Man is the person
the character at first glance you're
like nothing special not too deep then
you get to Vegas you're like wait a
minute you're like some sort of awesome
super genius
yeah it's that works they don't really
they don't go to Vegas and cabin in the
woods it's metaphorical you know what
that's my metaphor and I'm sticking to
it it works but all you know is that
it's about five college students who go
into a cabin and they got to survive you
walk out going
I had no idea what I was in for you see
how hard it is to review this movie
without me spoiling it for you feel like
I'm just like giving you scraps like
yeah it's cool that's what you get at a
point near the end of cabin in the woods
I thought to myself I was like this is
like a Stephen King novel you know like
back in his prime but for me it was
tense it was funny it was dark I love
the dialogue I love what this movie does
for horror movies so it's not like the
movie will win a pun too which is
probably why I'm gonna say cabin in the
woods is awesome tacular I had to do it
that was my main thing I was driving
home going is it buy it on blu-ray or
awesome tacular but it mean of loving a
good horror movie and loving Joss Whedon
and seeing everything I loved about Joss
Whedon and horror movies mixed into a
movie that celebrates horror movies and
deconstructs them in a really
entertaining way how could I not say
it's awesome tacular I would be an
if I didn't so what is your
favorite horror movie like they're all
going to get burned in a fire and you
can only keep one what is it comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
you